John Dickerson is CBS News chief
Washington correspondent he is also the
host of Face the Nation he joins us from
Washington John good morning morning
Charlie let's start with this question
what are the implications of this
because Mullis seems to be supported on
both sides of the aisle and he has
significant power to do so via the
implications for the president are that
think about this he said that the all
these investigations into Russia
collusion with the Trump campaign that
they were a witch-hunt that the FBI
investigation was was shouldn't go
anywhere now this investigation has been
reenergized it's been revalidated and
somebody's been put at the top that both
Republicans and Democrats have praised
so this can no longer be knocked down by
the President as a partisan witch hunt
and also the president now has to be
careful about what he says about it
because in the mix in this story now is
the off-the-books conversation he had
with former director Comey about
possibly wrapping up the investigation
so anything the president says now about
it has to be seen in that light where
people are talking about obstruction of
justice John do you have any information
on how the White House is feeling about
this latest turn of events we've heard
public statements well there you know
it's they feel whipsawed by what's being
up ten days of constant pounding I mean
and and a lot of the troubles
self-inflicted search some of it has
been newspaper reports about about
things but a lot of it also has been
just poor planning the Comey firing was
handled in a way that that just
exacerbated lots of problems that
couldn't get their story straight that's
been that's happened again with the
story about what the president may have
said in the Oval Office with the Russian
Foreign Minister so they are feeling
pretty battered over there so what
limitations are they on this special
counsel well the the limitations there
looks like there's not that many of them
and that and you have two things one the
way the powers that Muller's been given
looks like he can not only look at the
underlying question of Russia and the
Trump campaign but then anything that
comes up in the course of the
investigation that he would want to look
into and then you've just got his
reputation in the way he comports
himself which is to say he doesn't put
up with any nonsense and so he wants to
go investigate something and
but he tries to stop him that's not
going to be a quiet accession by him
he's going to do what he wants to do and
of course again he has that bipartisan
support from both parties which gives
him a lot of political power to I don't
want to lose sight of the fact that the
president leaves tomorrow on his first
foreign trip his first stop Saudi Arabia
he's going to have lunch with 50 leaders
from around the Muslim and Arab world
and there's significant deals that are
going to be announced right there are
significant deals this is a test not
only of the president but of his
administration the ability to lay out a
foreign trip with what they call
deliverables things that he can praise
the things that he can show that he has
relationships in these cities often
presidents have recouped when they are
in trouble by going overseas acting
presidential carrying off the the kind
of set-piece things that a president has
to do so this comes at the right time
but as former Secretary of Defense
Robert Gates said to us the president
has to stick to the script
and he's also gonna make a major speech
on Islam he is which will be really
fascinating given the many things that
he has said over the course of the
campaign and some of the things that
have been said by some of his close
advisers about the religion and its
connection to terrorism all right John
we will all be watching thank you very
much